regardez-moi le concept car qu'on a ici
Peugeot c'est l'inception Inception
c'est absolument incroyable le tableau
de bord qui est un écran incurvé en fait
ça c'est assez extraordinaire la
position qui a l'air je sais pas ça va
être très flatteur quand on est dedans
mais en tout cas ça a vraiment de la
gueule il y a un concept un peu
rétro-futuriste avec tout cette
expérience un petit peu en comment dire
en espèce d'aluminium à Sion c'est pas
réellement ce que c'est c'est un concept
qui bien évidemment ne verra jamais le
jour mais Peugeot est là pour séduire le
marchand américain avec ce concept là
qui est juste magnifique je regrette
qu'on n'est pas des pneumatiques
Michelin mais je trouve ça juste
extrêmement élégant très bien vu très
jolie des écrans tous les côtés même sur
l'extérieur ici il y a un petit côté je
trouve un peu Ford Mustang au niveau de
l'éclairage pas il y a beaucoup
d'inspiration j'ai l'impression de voir
un espèce de concept rétro-futurique
sorti l'univers de Mad Max voilà j'aime
ça c'est présent au CES 2023 je pense
que vous en pensez d'ailleurs
dites-le-moi dans les commentaires